hello everyone
my name is vinay kumar and today i'll be
presenting
joint work with uh venket guruswami on
the pseudobinomiality of the sticky
random walk
so i'll first discuss the context of our
project and then i'll introduce
the necessary background and then uh
we'll discuss
our main results and proofs and then
finally we'll end off with
some recent work that's been done by the
community
and future directions
all right so first our project
our project context is
takes place on the random walks over
expanders
so uh if you don't know what expanders
are expanders are
uh basically a type of graph that where
all the vertices are connected with each
other
but they don't use that many edges
and these graphs are very useful in
pseudorandomness
and it basically stems off of the fact
that
random walks on expanders uh
they're very good at simulating
pure randomness while using a small
amount of resources
and so these graphs they appear in many
explicit constructions of
various pseudorandom objects for example
uh pseudorandom generators
extractors air correcting codes or
error amplification protocols
and what our project is uh specifically
going to be dealing with
is um mathematically
what are all the statistical properties
of an expander walk uh that are very
pseudo-random like they're very
close to that of a purely random bit
string
so um just to review what an expander is
they're de-regular graphs and we think
of d as a
small in terms of the size
or in terms of the number of vertices
because we want it to be sparse
the combinatorial definition states that
any small vertex set small meaning
at most half the number of vertices
expands to a larger one so if i expand i
mean
if i uh add in all the
vertices that are adjacent to
one of the small set vertices
and i uh combine them into a bigger set
this bigger set is always
uh some multi some uh constant
uh scale larger than the small set
so in this example the green set is our
small set
and then when we expand it we get a blue
set
that is twice as large and so if it's
always twice as large
no matter what green set i chose uh
then i can call it an expander with a
size two uh like expansion factor
uh so that's the combinatorial
definition and it turns out there's an
equivalent
algebraic definition that has to do with
the
normalized adjacency matrix so it's
simply saying that the normalized
adjacency matrix if we take all of its
non-trivial eigenvalues and they're all
bounded
in magnitude by some constant less than
one
we call it uh like we call it a spectral
expander
uh and with some parameter which is
equal to that
constant bound on the eigenvalues so
clearly the combinatorial definition's
more intuitive but the algebraic
definition is easier to work with
just because algebra usually has more
structure than
combinatorics all right so in particular
a specific type of expander we're going
to look at is
one where we mark half of its vertices
to be black
and uh so now when we do a random walk
over it
we can analyze the indicator string that
indicates
whether uh the eighth step was marked or
not so as an example
here's a six step random one that i drew
out and
uh this random walk on this uh expander
that i marked half the nodes on
it creates this following bit string
where i put a zero
uh on the ike index if
uh that node was
white and then a one if that node was
black
so i i went white black black white
white black
so zero one one zero zero one like that
so
in particular what we're going to do is
we're going to just focus on symmetric
properties of the string
what i mean by that is we're just going
to look for a random walk we're just
going to look at
how many times in the random walk did we
visit
the marked vertices and this is
equivalent to saying we're only going to
look at the hamming weight
of this bit string we generate
so there has been results that uh study
like the hemming weight of that string
and uh we can list some important ones
for example
the number of visits uh is concentrated
about
n over two by some expanded turn-off
bounds and this was shown
uh early by gilman in the 1990s
and then it was also shown that the
parity bias was exponentially small
which means
the probability that the hamming weight
of the string is even or odd
is uh it's one half plus or minus
a very small exponential factor and
this property uh allowed tashma to
give a construction of almost optimal
epsilon balanced codes so along this
similar flavor we want to look at uh
other statistical properties of this
hamming weight and see
how they resemble the
binomial distribution and why the
binomial distribution it's because the
hemingway of a purely random string
follows the binomial distribution and so
this is what we call pseudobinomiality
we want to find
the pseudo binomiality of the number of
visits aka
how close the distribution of the number
of visits is
to the binomial distribution in
particular
uh we take a modest step in this
direction
uh by looking at a specific class of
marked expanders which we call the
sticky random walk
and so now let us define what the sticky
random walk is the sticky random walk
it uh it has two parameters uh n
which is the number of steps and then
lambda
which can be intuitively thought of as
the stickiness factor
and it's it also turns out it's a proxy
for the eigenvalue the expander's second
largest eigenvalue
so the sticky walk is going to be
distribution over bit strings
uh and how it works is it's a two-state
markov chain where the first bit's
determined uniformly at random
and then every subsequent bit will stick
to the current bit we're on with
probability one plus lambda over two
and then with remaining probability
it'll swap to the other bit
and so that's why lambda is called a
stickiness factor because
we if lambda is equal to 0 if we have no
stickiness
we basically stay with probability half
and move with probably half and so this
is a purely random string
and then if lambda is equal to one this
walk is very sticky because after the
first
step we essentially stick to that first
bit
forever because with probability one uh
we'll stay
uh will stay at the initial bit and so
we'll just get zero zero zero zero zero
one one one one one and i'll use the
convention that
uh the magnitude of b a bit string is
equal to its hamming weight
the number of ones in the bit string
so how do we know that the sticky walk
and expander walk are related
so it's it's been folklore in the
community that
like this is like
a a walk that resembles the expander
walk and so we make it precise
uh in the following theorem where um
we show that the sticky walk is
essentially a special case
of an expander walk where the where
uh the expander has second largest
eigenvalue lambda
and so in particular any bound or result
we find in the sticky walk
cannot be improved in the more general
setting of the expander lock
and so this shows that the sticky walk
is a necessary proxy towards
understanding the general
expander so let's go to
our main result here so here we show
pseudobinomiality result in the form
of a total variation distance bound so
note that this is
more stronger than uh established
various scene bounds
so let uh s be a sticky walk uh
distribution uh string and then let t be
a purely random
string so we can basically bound the
total variation distance
between uh the distribution of the
hamming weights of these
two strings uh by theta of lambda
and uh i just wrote it out here like the
the uh hamming weight just the
distribution of the hamming weight of t
is
just the binomial distribution and then
this is
the distribution of the sticky walk so
something like uh this theorem comes
into power
when we think of lambda small because
for large lambda like
the total variation distance is uh
bounded by one
but uh we basically capture the
asymptotic
decay of the total variation distance as
lambda equals
as lambda goes to zero precisely
all right so um the
basically the new idea that we use in
order to prove this
is uh we essentially do fourier analysis
over uh this walk the hamming weight of
this walk
uh using a special basis uh crowd chip
functions
and this basis is special because it's
especially useful for
uh these pseudo-binomiality type things
and the reason being
is uh they're orthogonal with respect to
uh inner product that is defined
in terms of the binomial distribution as
you see here
and if you work with this basis you
start noticing that
the k sub zero coefficient essentially
represents how binomial the distribution
is
and then so the remaining terms the k1
through kn
coefficients they basically measure
how much it deviates away from the
binomial distribution
in a very uh intuitive and informal
sense
and so it turns out you basically just
have to upper bound
uh the total var
in order to bound the trovation distance
you just have to
upper bound like the sum of the
remaining terms
as shown here and we'll define what g
is later but essentially g will
represent
like a normalized version of the sticky
uh
random walk distribution
so let me now define what the crowd trig
functions are
uh the crowd check functions are defined
by this expression here
we sum over all bit strings with having
weight k
of negative 1 to the alpha dot y
for any bit string alpha with hamming
weight
l and it doesn't matter which bit string
because this
expression is symmetric with respect to
alpha
now we have these uh inner product
relationship that we
discussed in the last slide and from
this you can calculate the norm
relationship so these are orthogonal
when r is not equal to s
and then when r is equal to s you can
calculate the norm squared is
and choose r and then from this
relationship
you can then calculate uh what the
explicit
uh fourier coefficients will be
simply by using the inner product and
uh you get this the k fourier
coefficient is this
so now we're ready to uh dive into the
proof
this is the problem statement restated
and
uh we now rewrite our total variation
distance as a binomial expectation
and we get this and so we basically
divided by the binomial distribution and
turned this probability into a g
of l which is basically a normalized
version of the sticky walk
and our idea now is to crouch expand g
and then upper bound it upper bound the
error terms
as we basically hinted towards in
previous slides
so first we convert this
l1 type
sum into an l2 type sum just because l2
things are usually easier and now by
parsables and evaluating the
coefficients
the square so first off um
you can verify that the zeroth
coefficient
in the kraut chick expansion is indeed
going to be uh
is indeed going to be cancelled out with
this one here
and so we'll be left with the sum from 1
to n and then by partials
you get this relationship because we
know the norm squared is this
and then now by the definition of
the coefficients uh we you know how we
can evaluate these coefficients
we get that this basically equals
this expression here so now we've we're
trying to
evaluate this expression one thing to
note is that
our binomial expectation is now
turned into a sticky wok expectation and
it turns out that evaluating uh
a sticky wok expectation of the crowd
shoot functions
uh is quite nice and it lends us to
it leads us to exactly find out uh
what these expectations are equal to and
then with that we can
upper bound asymptotically this sum
so this is the precise lemma for uh
non-negative integers k and s we
basically can calculate exactly
what these expectations are and the
proof
it's it's a it's a cute uh counting
argument
uh in the similar flavor of like balls
and urns
and then what we do next is
uh we derive a bound
on this l2 type uh
sum that we were working with in the
last slide
this should be squared here uh this is
the tvd but we're actually working with
the squared version
and so for lambda small enough we can
upper bound this to be of lambda squared
and the proof of this it's not too
interesting it's just
uh a lot of like arithmetic
uh using generating functions and then
approximating
expressions but once we have that
uh we're done because again
we have this uh okay again this should
be an l1
type norm and so this l1 norm by koshi's
upmost this
squared of this l2 type
expectation and then by using this lemma
we get o of lambda here
and so that gives our total variation
distance result
so there's a second result i want to go
over
and this is essentially trying to unify
two results so as we hinted
uh in previous slides a churn off bound
was used to show that the hamming weight
of the expander walk is concentrated
about n over two
and tashma used some spectral norm
bounding
to show the parity bias was
exponentially small
so we have chernoff type arguments
and spectral norm type arguments which
are two different arguments
but is there a way to somehow combine
these two results and
as as a way of trying to quantify what
we mean by combining these two results
we show as a modest step um we look at
how the majority bit and the parity bit
is correlated so majority bit is
basically like
if the hemming weight's above n over two
it's one if it's below n over two it's
zero
and then parity bit it's zero even one
is odd
so um we do show
such an uncorrelation result using crowd
trig functions again and this is uh
this is uh the precise statement the
probability
uh that the hamming weight of an n-step
sticky walk is even
and larger than n over two it's uh
one-fourth plus some lower order term
and of course this is the same
for even odd or larger and smaller than
and uh the proof idea is uh it's a lot
of symmetry
and then from the symmetry you basically
red you base the symmetry basically uh
makes everything cancel out with each
other with the exception of like the
middle
term which is the probability the uh
hamming weight is equal to n over two
and so that's why
um the problem of bounding the central
coefficient
uh becomes important and so we show a
bound on this
uh which is at most uh o
of n to the negative 1 4.
all right so let's uh talk about this
now so i've
drawn all four cases basically
like of parity uh and majority into this
uh table here so our end goal is to show
that every single
probability here is one-fourth
very close to one point one-fourth plus
low-low of one
so let's start off with the top row and
bottom row the top row is
all the uh strings of hamming weight at
least n over two
and the bottom strings with hamming
weight less than n over two
so one can check that if i have a string
and then i toggle all of its bits uh
it's gonna have the same probability in
the sticky walk distribution
and so um that
immediately gives us that the top row
and bottom row
uh only differ by at most uh
the probability this probability the
probability of this
uh middle cases and then i'm leaving out
constant factors because it's not
important and now let's look at the left
row and the right row
um so the left and right oh sorry
left column and right column the left
and right columns it turns out
they differ by at most lambda to the n
over two so it's
exponentially small and uh
this is by direct calculation in fact
you can
if you write out this uh difference it
turns out
it's actually a special case of the
expectation of
a function and so you can explicitly
calculate it to be some constant times
lambda to the n over 2. so great what we
know now is that
the left and right row differ
uh by a small amount and then the top
row and bottom row differ by small
amount but what does that mean
all that means all that means uh is that
the diagonal entries are very close to
each other
but that's not enough right to deduce
that all four
uh boxes have probability one-fourth
plus or minus a little
so what we need to show is uh
that the left cell and the right cell
are very close
and the left cell and right cell here
are very close if we show that then we
can deduce that all four
uh square entries in the table are
very close together and so
um to do so again it's a symmetric
argument here
so we define we basically look
at a map which we define by toggling
a specific bit a certain bit and so when
we do that
um it basically it preserves the
probability that this
string has the same probability in the
sticky watch distribution
and it also toggles the parity of the
string
so it's essentially we're trying to make
a bijection between
uh the left cell and the right cell but
it's not exactly a bijection there's
some
rogue strings that
make it not in bijection for example
if i had a string that was that had
hamming weight really close to n over
two
then toggling the bit string would cause
it
might cause it to have hamming weight
less than n over two
so we have to basically
uh group up all of these uh rogue cases
and then look at the error they make
so it turns out there's only a linear
amount of such
bad strings and each of them have really
small
probability and so
that is irrelevant essentially
and then uh so basically from all that
work we basically show that
this bit flipping
map it shows that the left cell and
right cell are very close
and so the only the it turns out the
largest error term since everything was
exponentially small
is uh the bottleneck is just going to be
this probability
of the having weight of s is equal to n
over two
and so we this is where crowdcheck
functions come in
so crouching functions come in here when
we prove
that the central
coefficient is asymptotically at most n
to the negative 1
4. the proof outline
is uh we basically crowd check expand
the corresponding characteristic
function
uh where it's one if the hemingway's n
over two
and zero otherwise and so once we crouch
expend that we can then upper bound the
resulting
uh expression we get
and so this gives us our error term
which is little of one
in terms of n and so since this was the
bottleneck
uh error term it follows our one-fourth
plus little of one thing follows because
all four entries in the table are
exactly the same
so there's been some exciting recent
work uh
by cohen perry and tashma uh
and in their paper titled expander
random walks
a fourier analytic approach and uh
some of the uh cool results they derive
is a total ration distance bound for
uh a general expander walk not just a
sticky random walk
uh and so in our paper
we showed an o of lambda uh
bound on the sticky random walk
so they show an o of uh o of lambda
times log to the three halves of one
over lambda
or an o tilde of lambda bound on
the general expander setting
and so the approach they use is uh
quite similar in in spirit what they do
is
instead of uh calculating
the hamming weight of the sticky walk
and the expectation of that
they carefully compute uh the
expectation of
the crowd choke function on the
expander uh the expander bit string
heavyweight and so uh
there's a natural question that arises
is um
can we simplify can we remove this log
factor
uh in order to get this o of lambda
bound
for the general expander walk too and
uh another thing they improved upon
is a upper bound on the central
coefficient
of the of the having weight
for expander walks so if you recall
we showed an n to the negative one
fourth bound uh
using some careful analysis they were
able to show
an n to the negative one-half bound for
this
function so
there's some future directions that are
yet to be
resolved for example as i said in the
last slide can we establish an of lambda
bound
for the general expander walk also
can crouch and fourier analysis
unify the parity and majority results
for the expander walk
uh right now we we've basically shown a
correlation result
but um it really depended a lot on
the symmetric uh the symmetric
properties of the sticky walk and so
that's why
uh the
bound of n to the negative one half
shown here could not
be really extended to show an anti
to show a uncorrelation result
so is there a way uh rather than
symmetry
and using maybe some crowd trigger
fourier analysis
to show such an uncorrelation result
and then another interesting question is
um
is there a way we can reduce the general
expander
setting uh in some ways to the sticky
walk setting
so for example uh there are moment
generating function results by kahale
and raura guev
that show that the expander walk
hamming weight mgf is
upper bounded by a certain case of
like a a bit general version of the
sticky random walk and so this allows us
to uh lift uh bounds on monotone
symmetric functions
uh from the sticky walk to
the expander walk so is there some
result we can show
that can lift bounds for non-monotone
functions
like parity uh and so that's another
question
so are there more is there a more
general class of
events that we can sort of lift from
a simpler sticky walk to
a general expander walk and so that's
all i have
for this talk thank you for listening
and